[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
good morning good monday morning
memorial day weekend
[Music]
we
remember all that all the fallen and all
the lost
this weekend
a lot of stuff going around the social
media about memorial day i have a few
videos that i want to show you
um
there was a picture that brought my
attention to the vietnam veterans
memorial
uh to those who had fallen in vietnam
and i watched a few videos this morning
and i want to show you those those
couple videos some archive footage
um and then a vice news piece that was
done a couple years ago i found very
interesting i figured you guys might
like to see some of that stuff on
memorial day
we are live
here every single monday through friday
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
and twitch and now simulcasting from the
midas touch facebook page we don't take
a day off here it might be a national
holiday
but i still yelling screaming to the
microphone
and boy
do we have
not i mean there is some yelling and
screaming to do today into the
microphone but more than anything it's
uh
we got a goof on these somba [ __ ]
whoo there's a lot of stuff going on
over the week you've seen the title of
the show this is episode 150 150 folks
peach tree dish
what a [ __ ] bonehead
oh
nice [ __ ] [ __ ] marjorie taylor green
they really are in a [ __ ] competition
of who is the dumbest the absolute
dumbest
congressperson
like they just
can't stop
mo brooks even on fox news
tripping over himself
sycophant for the former guy
for the manga king king diapers
and we watched lauren bobert
a video of her last week
but we also have some senators that are
on the list today and wayne lapierre
you remember wayne lapierre
from the nra and there's a great great
video
that the good liars did and they got a
chance to speak directly to wayne
lapierre
uh at the nra convention so we're gonna
play that and then i've got a uh a
classic george carlin clip about wayne
lapierre that i'd like to play as well
you know i'm a big george garland fan
you guys haven't seen the documentary
have you if you haven't go watch it
if you can if you have hbo max or hbo it
is it is an absolute wonderful
uh documentary on
the late great
philosopher and comedian george carlin
you can tell a lot of my work is
influenced by
by georgie
so go take a look at that we're gonna
we're gonna watch a clip today on the
show of george but we're also gonna
watch some clips on the um again the
vietnam
veterans memorial that was built in
washington dc it was
inducted in 1982 so it's been quite some
time but it caught my attention
it's been 40 years now but it caught my
attention
this morning from a picture that someone
had posted and i was like hmm
and i'm going to go search this and uh i
found some a couple of videos that i
want to show you guys so we're going to
look at that and then we're going to
look at a ton we're going to surf the
tweety tweets and eternity trends like
we always do here on the tony michaels
podcast
because we got a lot of video to get to
so hopefully gabe will join us at the
bottom of the hour our co-host executive
producer gabe sanchez i also have a
video i want to show you of gabe's that
he did that we aired
we gave you a teaser the other day and
then it debuted on the midas touch
youtube channel
a fantastic debut of what was that
what was that
so we're going to play
play the debut
episode again today in its full form so
you guys can see it so stay with us
today i appreciate you coming and
joining us here on memorial day
again if you have veterans out there or
no veterans out there especially the
ones who are falling and family members
that are falling
um
send send love to them today
we want to do that we want to do that uh
so let's let's start off i i don't know
maybe we'll just go to this picture that
i uh that i found
of this veteran um it is actually
uh here is the let's bring it up here
here's the picture
here of the veteran holding a flag now
let me make it a little bigger here
there we go and if you guys are
listening on the directories you should
come over and subscribe to the youtube
channel that way you can watch it every
once in a while so you can see what we
see um
on the screen is a is an elderly
gentleman
he has a a uniform on
he's holding a flag and he
um
he's looking like he's remembering
something
and um the tweet here
was from dr gutterman that says
remembering those who gave the ultimate
sacrifice for the united states
this photo is via u.s department of
defense the man's name is joseph ambrose
a world war one veteran
and this is at the 1982 dedication day
parade
for vietnam veterans memorial and
holding the flag that covered the casket
of his son
who was killed in the korean war
so
three wars in this picture here and he
was there to
help commemorate
uh the
inauguration of the vietnam wars
veterans uh war memorial
in washington dc in 1985 holding the
flag that uh
was draped over his son's casket in the
in the korean war
and he is a world war one
veteran
um so three wars in this one picture and
that led me that led me to uh go look up
a few things
on the tubes of you
um i figured
you know what i want to know more
about this
i want to know more about this vietnam
memorial and what the history of it is
because i cuz i know i know um
from studying in the past that
it it was
you know
um
it was
at one time
a very contentious thing there was a lot
of
problems that happened
when they were trying to
bring this memorial
about uh in the design who designed it
that sort of thing
but i want to um i want to play
first i want to play the
[Music]
a um historical archived footage
of
this memorial
um so let me get it cued here
so let's play this video here
i believe this is from 1980
the vietnam veterans memorial is
considered to be one of the most iconic
monuments in the country
actually this is this is the second one
i want to play excuse me here let's
let's um
that is not the exact one i want to play
i want to play a different one
i want to play some archived footage
here first
the world repeat
so here is the archive footage
i was looking for
there were repeated comments of long
overdue long overdue as the vietnam
veterans memorial was dedicated in
washington today and thousands of
vietnam veterans marched on constitution
avenue bruce morton has our report
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the parade was for the veterans
impromptu groups sometimes stopping to
sing patriotic songs like the rest of
the day the official program was the
least important part mostly the day was
people people who had served people who
had mourned people and the wall
a father who had lost his son that was
the last thing that jim said dad i love
my country i don't want to go but i love
my country
so uh that gives me
an uplift to know that
he loved this country he didn't want to
go but he was willing to sacrifice his
life and he did after 30 days over there
a soldier who'd come back all these
people on these walls my friend
as far as i'm concerned
i wish they could have did something a
long time ago we didn't need no parades
or that all we needed was a little bit
of respect
respect was all around today the
patriots of an earlier american war
talked of risking their lives their
fortunes and their sacred honor
the lives that were lost remain lost of
course young men denied their chance at
fortune but maybe today the americans
who went to war and those who didn't
maybe they all regained some honor
standing before this monument
we see reflected in a dark mirror dimly
a chance now to let go of the pain
the grief
the resentment
the bitterness
the guilt
this was a day when it was all right for
grown men to cry thank you america thank
you finally for remembering us memory
honor names on a wall full of memory
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
the vietnam veterans memorial
is now dedicated
[Applause]
one of the team who carved the names
into the vietnam memorial is a memphis
woman pat floyd had fell her lock to
etch into line 36 of stone 29 the name
peter p barry blasco blasco was mrs
floyd's brother who was killed in 1968
calling the work on his stone extremely
emotional mrs floyd said she had planned
to attend the dedication but she said i
finally called my family and i said i
just couldn't do it
so there you have um that video there um
from the
archive footage from 1982
and we are going to go back to the last
video or repeated comments of long
overdue
last video here
this is from vice news it kind of
explains the history
of the vietnam veterans memorial
was a very very um
rough time after the vietnam war
the vietnam veterans weren't being
honored
not just the ones who were still alive
but even the ones who had died is the
war torn our punch country apart almost
torn half
tore families apart they kind of
explained that in the
in the piece here from vice news
um
smells a little similar if you know what
i mean
but the vietnam
veterans memorial
somewhat put those pieces back together
because of that event
um
the war it is
and the the
disagreement in the country about the
war so let's
let's watch um
that piece here
and we will
see the history
of that memorial
the vietnam veterans memorial is
considered to be one of the most iconic
monuments in the country
but organizers didn't think they'd see
their plans to honor those who served
come to fruition
before groundbreaking on march 26 1982
the monument was mired in almost as much
controversy as the war it set out to
memorialize
[Applause]
the vietnam war was the most divisive
event of the 20th century it pulled
people apart it pulled families apart it
would take the nation a while to recover
there was a feeling that it was time to
forget about it move on and which made
perfect sense
but i'm a combat veteran i could not
allow them to forget the veterans
i decided that my mission in life was to
build a national vietnam veterans
memorial
with the names of those who enjoyed
their lives
and to try to put it on the mall in
washington dc
we decided that we would have a
competition open to any american aged 18
years old or older every entry had to
have one thing a way to display the 58
000 names of the casualties from the
vietnam war
[Music]
we had a jury of a very well respected
architect when they saw this design they
kept coming back to it because all the
other designs were complex a young yale
architectural student maya ying lin has
won the competition to design
washington's newest memorial
to me it looked like a bat or maybe a
boomerang
i couldn't understand how in the world
this was going to work
however
because i respected the people on the
jury so much i stood up and applauded
and said this is a work of genius
we can't wait to build it
probably two days after the design was
announced i got a call from a paralyzed
veteran in vietnam and he just said look
this is
outrageous this is a black hole in the
ground
one of the opponents to this we're
asking
what kind of inscription do you think we
should have on the wall
and he said i've got an idea for you put
this on there scruggs designed by a [ __ ]
had the design been done by a regular
you know six foot four
white guy with blue eyes we might have a
lot less controversy
we needed to make a compromise with
these people ultimately we had a meeting
and everybody agreed this could be
modified properly
with a statue
a flagpole and then the opponent said no
that's not enough
i was a white house fellow at the time
and was assigned to represent the white
house at meetings to discuss the future
of the memorial we had already secured
the approvals we required
the opponents of the memorial were
attempting to stop the permit from being
issued
they were all calling
the secretary of the interior logging
his phone with messages and demanding
that he not give us the construction
permit so
all of a sudden all this work was up in
smoke
we had run out of ammunition except for
one thing
his name was tom shaw
and he went up to the interior
department
and he said the white house was fully
behind us and the president
and that we needed to get this done we
didn't want to have
this delayed any further
i didn't have formal approval
but i did have a sense from the senior
staff that they would support me on this
i understood that
you know this is a moment in time when
we had to move quickly we had to make a
decision
and it was the right thing to do
we got the permit and within days we had
construction crews on the ground
we had bulldozers tearing holes all over
the mall
and we made such a mess nobody could
ever stop for construction
somehow we prevailed
the memorial changed everything from
vietnam veterans all of a sudden
everyone's proud to be a vietnam veteran
everybody shakes their hands and they
get to stand up during baseball games
now all americans can agree that vietnam
veterans deserve recognition and
appreciation for their sacrifices and
that is why the vietnam veterans
memorial stands here today
and in 1982 the memorial was dedicated
to 50 000 vietnam veterans there
and they embraced the wall the nation
embraced the wall
it was pretty apparent that
this was going to have a profound impact
on what needed to happen which was to
heal the wounds of the war
so there you have some of the
controversy over the
vietnam veterans memorial um
ultimately in 1982
it was dedicated and has been ever since
and many people go to that wall
every year to see the names some
names that they know
so
keep that in mind on today and it's not
just the vietnam war we have uh recent
wars in the last 20 years
um
the gulf war
the korean war
the second world war the first world war
um all losing family friends
heroes lost
as we remember memorial day
a lot of people think it's for all
veterans which we should remember all
veterans that serve our country
honorably to their oath
but today today is a day that we
remember
the fallen
the fallen soldiers
um that
fought and died
to give us our liberty
for the rights and the freedoms that are
the vehicle
to the liberty
in which we seek
and that is in the constitution
for equality and equity for every single
person in this country
those fallen soldiers
fought for us to kneel during the
national anthem
fought for us to protest in the streets
against fascists trying to take away our
rights to our bodies
gave us the ability
to make sure that we secured our vote to
select a government that would work for
the people
by the people
and for the people
and that is what we have to do this year
we have to show
that their
fault those fallen soldiers did not fall
in vain
we must protect our constitution we must
protect our democracy
whether you're conservative you're
liberal
you're republican you're democrat you're
an independent you're libertarian
remember the sacrifice that those
families those mothers those fathers
sisters brothers husbands wives made
for their loved ones
to give the ultimate sacrifice
to our country
remember that on this day
hang right with us we will be right back
with the tweety tweets and trendy trends
my co-host gabe sanchez is going to join
us stick around right after this break
we are going to go back to the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends
hang tight
[Music]
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
drupists mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your drew today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
[Music]
we have with us the the extraordinary
co-host
an executive producer
and also
the new correspondent of what was that
you guys catch did you guys catch the uh
debut of what was that
gabe hey he had a great debut of what
what what what was that what was that
what was that what was that i'm sorry
what was that yeah yeah i was uh i was
very
very glad to see that it did well on the
debut um
i honestly didn't know how people would
respond to it you know they could be
like oh it's [ __ ] lib [ __ ]
trying to
there was an overwhelming amount of
people who were like this is great more
this awesome you know so
it's fantastic well you know because you
you were you were working on several
episodes at once and i think you have a
couple more this week possible yeah i've
got another i mean of course
obviously margery taylor green that's
going to be a whole episode itself
uh but yeah i i have one on trump's uh
nra speech so i'm i'm good working good
working
um you know because it was about gun
safety and today is um
memorial day where we um we memorialize
those who have fallen those veterans who
have fallen but also we we want to
remember those veterans but man there
was a video going around
over the weekend from a marine corps
veteran
his name is matt he goes by united
states marine corps angry veteran
um did you see this did you happen to
catch this video you know matt i think
yeah so i know i know matt through tick
tock actually we were
uh
i i connected with him back in 2020 i
feel like through some other people uh
who are also like kind of politically
charged using tick tock for that means
um
and there and he has a lot of gems in
there um this one specifically but he
has some other ones where just dumb
people come in and you know question his
his service and this and then he's like
all right
i'm gonna i'm right fine you want to do
that let's go and i think it's the long
hair and the beard that make them
question yeah well he's also i think i
think that i mean like matt's also an
actor like i'm sure he's more of a stage
actor as well
but
uh he's also like a comic book star wars
nerd like he's a fun guy he's you know
he's great um and i think it might be
the long hair and the beard which by the
way i don't i think that was
i think that is a covered like
uh quarantine oh so so this was this was
uh this is post covered
well i mean it was like durian during
covid grew out the hair oh weird yeah
well you know i i grew up longer beard
during yeah but i try to well yeah
is it are you still working on it is
that yeah
i mean it is
cindy's giving me hell here saul i say
scene yeah yeah you see this is
this is when i when i seen it you know i
seeked it because uh i'm a hillbilly i'm
a redneck so i've seen you know i've
seen a lot of stuff whatever it might be
you know whatever it is whatever it is
uh you're not you're not gonna you're
not gonna change this old
this little dog but but back to the
matt's video here it really kind of went
viral it's got like four million views
just on twitter because what he's
talking about here is um some of the
ideas that he put forth on tick tock he
did and i went to his account because he
did another video
that led up to this and someone
responded to that video about some of
the suggestions that he had made and
this was kind of their response to them
because some of his suggestions were
like um you know you should have to keep
them locked away in a specific way um
you should have to recertify and
re-license and know that you know how to
handle the weapon every year so so matt
here
right stan well matt standard stuff for
the military right because matt here is
suggesting that we shouldn't just ban
uh these types of guns we should just
make it really [ __ ] difficult to own
one right right
i mean he's not saying ban assault
rifles which i kind of think is probably
a good answer to our problem but what
he's suggesting here
is to to make it really [ __ ]
difficult for someone to own one and
keep one now right
which you know there can be a lot of
different playing fields here when
you're talking about
um having reasonable common sense gun
reform and i i think matt makes a good
case for this uh in his prior video and
so i reached out to matt and i think uh
wednesday we're gonna have him on the
show because i really want to talk to
him because he seems you know he was in
the military and he has he has a really
good sense of what gun control actually
looks like what i mean by that you'll
kind of know after this video here is he
has a really good sense of what gun
control because people who are like
actually trained to use these weapons
who are who are who
dedicate their lives dedicate their life
sometimes give the ultimate sacrifice
right and especially for matt you know
being an instructor right right which i
believe he mentions in this video too
he's like i'm not just some person who
served like i was the person who also
made sure that we followed the protocol
for the like for the next cohort
of marines that came in like to make
sure that they were instilling the same
procedure it wasn't just like you got a
gun on your pillow that's good enough
for me you know right right because
let's actually keep track of this stuff
because for them it's not just about the
gun itself it's about the safety of the
human beings right like like um
we spend a lot of money training
and and making sure that our soldiers
are very knowledgeable right with
weapons and these types of weapons and
even weapons that are way beyond the
capacity of what we would see even um on
some of our streets like the ar-15 is
just a really good example but he kind
of explains it here what gun control
actually looks like and how the military
actually
has a lot
of gun control like a ladder
really weird to keep those
humans in the military
safe and make sure that you know
you know they're not harmed by
gunfire so let's listen to matt's video
here and the case that he makes
for why gun control works because it
works in this country
in the military let's listen
i'm glad that you said that you're a
marine corps veteran because i wanted to
bring this point up how many times a
year do you have to go as a marine to
re-qualify and prove that you are
competent and proficient in the weapons
that you have been issued
i'll answer that for you as a former
rifle pistol coach in the marine corps
you have to go annually
and how long does that take two weeks
right you have a week of grass week and
then a week of live fire isn't that
right so in the marine corps you have to
go for two weeks out of your life and
prove to the marine corps that you are
still proficient and the weapons that
have been issued to you now was taken a
step further let's say you're a private
through a sergeant that's living in the
barracks in the marine corps are you
allowed to store a firearm in your
barracks room the answer is no you are
not if you privately own a weapon you
have to go and register that weapon with
the provost marshal's office and then
they issue a receipt to you saying where
your weapon will be stored and kept safe
for you why is it that the united states
marine corps the finest fighting force
on the planet
is more restricted and who and where
firearms can be stored and possessed
than the average 18 year old in the
state of texas
why you see your plan is to just do
nothing and ignore the problem and
continue to pray and hope that it goes
away well guess what erica that's not
[ __ ] working
okay that is not [ __ ] working let's
look at the second amendment for a
second all right the second amendment
says a well
regulated militia if you believe that
the second amendment applies to all
citizens and all citizens are supposed
to be that militia what do you think
well
regulated means
it doesn't mean
no
regulations
jesus christ why is this so [ __ ] hard
to understand
doing nothing
makes it easier for children to get
slaughtered in their schools
[ __ ] all the way off
he he didn't really hold any punches
there with this video
and and i have to say like you know
doing political videos on tick tock i
totally understand the frustration i
mean this obviously is something that
like rings true to him right because he
has experienced it he has gone through
this training he's you know a veteran he
knows exactly what he's talking about
but i also think that you know much like
others who do political content on tick
tock there is a level of frustration and
probably those also who who make content
for twitter as well like you have
complete idiots and people who want to
come in and say oh you know what i know
exactly what i'm talking about and they
really just read a wikipedia article
they read some opinion piece and the
wall street journal or whatever it might
be
but
uh
there are tons of people who try to
[Music]
make themselves seem like they're an
expert on some field specifically
something like this and then get
challenged all the way to go [ __ ]
themselves
and proven or wrong by people like matt
which is great because we need more of
this we need more people calling out we
need more people speaking up we need
more people taking action because if we
don't then we have more idiots who are
like oh the second amendment rights this
man i'm gonna have and go wherever i
want my gun it's like
he just showed you right if you actually
knew what the second amendment said it
mentions a well-regulated which is the
antithesis
of the republican party right the
republican party wants
no regulation there are anti-regulations
what ends up happening is that when you
do that then you get people who are
running amok in the streets and doing
whatever they want whether it's owning
guns
or the financial sector or whatever it
might be you've got people without
regulation
it's the [ __ ] purge right like that's
what ends up happening
right so to see people like matt speak
up
you know especially on their experience
and their knowledge is awesome
and i don't like i completely understand
where he's coming from like the
frustration that i have just seen [ __ ]
on twitter i'm like
wow
it is insane well speaking of twitter go
follow matt on twitter i put the uh his
handle in the chat there at usmc angry
vet on twitter and i think he's usmc
angry veteran on tick-tock
yeah is that correct yeah let me just
look it up real quick i think that's
right and once you find it stick it in
the chat there for the tick tock account
but i think it's a usmc angry veteran on
tick tock but a usmc angry vet on
twitter so follow matt
give him some love on all the social
medias i think he's on instagram too so
um i'm not sure which handle he's got on
instagram but if you go to one of them
i'm sure he's got like a link tree or
something where you can find all his
accounts and so thanks man for that for
that video someone else made a video
over the weekend oh yeah oh
he made it he he made it about yuvaldi
um who is this guy
what was it what was that what was that
what
was that what was that we did a debut of
well teaser the other day and then you
debuted this on the midas touch youtube
channel and it got spread around um
uh twitter so i wanted to play it here
today i think this series is gonna
go very well especially here on the tony
michaels podcast we're gonna um we're
gonna try to force gabe do at least 20
of these a day
if i if i could uh i totally would
um i don't really have a team of interns
or a studio where like
the goal here is like if i can just
photoshop them in games yeah photoshop
just have to be like i want to give a
special chance to intern one two right
three yeah ai ai is a is a hell of a
drug it is at this point um
but the other thing too is like um
because this is intended to have like
kind of a late night host kind of style
like a daily show or stephen colbert or
someone like that where
there's a little bit of comedy involved
in here like there's some jokes that are
thrown out you'll see some photoshopped
you know images that are there
uh but also delivering you the facts of
of what's going on telling you the story
of what's going on and hopefully
the message coming through um
about what i'm talking about so that's
what i'm you know if i had a full team
and i was able to run this live and have
a whole like
well maybe
maybe one of these days maybe one of
these days we'll afford right now it's
just a one-man gift shop it's just one
man's shop on this what was that so
he's asked me a few things about the
script and stuff but gabe has pretty
much done this entire
uh project on his own i i told you a
while back i guess there's about a month
or so ago i'm like hey man you need a
you need a segment where you're
you know talking about certain uh news
stories
and uh you know do it two or three times
a week and this is kind of what we came
up with because a lot of people like the
satire videos that you do and i was like
and and you had suggested
uh the late night kind of series right
here it is here of course it debuted on
minus touch but here it is in full on
the tony michaels podcast the very first
what was that what was that on tuesday
may 24th 19 young children and two
adults were killed in a school shooting
in uvalde texas it took over 90 minutes
to stop the shooter but it has now been
revealed that some police officers
breached the school to get their own
children out before
the shooter was taken down
[Music]
texas law enforcement officials have
changed their stories so many times i
wouldn't be surprised if we find out
they personally escorted the gunman into
the school this was the deadliest
american school shooting since the 2012
massacre at sandy hook elementary this
is the 27th school shooting this year we
have had 213 mass shootings in less than
six months of 2022. you don't need to be
enrolled in ron desantis school of band
mathematics to know how bad these
numbers are the uvalde shooting happened
just 10 days after the horrific shooting
at the buffalo supermarket on may 14th
we unfortunately live in a country where
guns outnumber people and gun violence
has become an everyday occurrence the
correlation between the number of guns
in america and the number of gun-related
deaths in america is undeniable maybe
this slaughtering of innocent children
is a wake-up call for republicans they
are the pro-life party after all and
they've said on multiple occasions they
want to save the children i'm sure by
now texas senator ted cruz has offered a
solution one of the things that that
everyone agreed is don't have all of
these unlocked back doors have one door
into and out of the school i'm sorry
what was that have one door into and out
of the school his solution to mass
shootings is one door i mean why stop
there let's make it a doggy door instead
that's small enough for children to fit
through you know for a brief moment i
really thought ted cruz is going to be
helpful
and then i remember that ted cruz also
tried to ban dildos okay forget cancun
cruz let's try texas attorney general
ken paxton we need to continue to try to
focus on preventing this we we can't
stop bad people from doing bad things
they're going to violate murder laws
they're not going to follow gun laws
i've never understood that argument but
we are we can't harden these goals we
can
create points of access that are
difficult to get through we can
potentially arm and prepare and train
teachers and other administrators to
respond quickly because the reality is
we don't have the resources to have law
enforcement at every school hold on the
gop who is notorious for banning books
and not giving teacher school supplies
wants to give teachers guns instead
giving teachers guns and placing armed
guards in schools does not protect
students from mass shootings in fact one
study found that schools with armed
guards were more likely to have a higher
debt hold during the mass shooting but
in ken paxton's fantasy world a teacher
arrives on their first day at remington
rifle elementary and goes through their
classroom checklist construction paper
check erasers check nine millimeter
smith and wesson check and then of
course when that plan ultimately fails
arming those children that republicans
forced women to birth is their backup
plan because nothing stops a bad guy
with a gun like a child with a gun and i
can see it now little timmy goes off to
school with his bulletproof backpack an
ar-15 in a toy story lunch box full of
bullets i'm sorry but the fact that we
live in a country that assumes a random
civilian should risk their own life to
save another is incredibly deranged but
now that i think about it maybe we
shouldn't take advice from the guy
that's currently being investigated by
the fbi also how did this guy just win
his primary anyway why don't we just go
further up the leadership chain and try
texas governor greg abbott oh here's a
tweet from abbott where he talks about
gun ownership i'm embarrassed texas
number two in nation for new gun
purchases behind california let's pick
up the pace texans at nra uh okay that's
embarrassing i didn't fully read the
tweet until right now okay here's a
video of abbott signing gun legislation
in 2021 i'm sure this prevents future
shootings i'm signing seven laws to
protect second amendment rights in the
lone star state joined by lieutenant
governor dan patrick house speaker david
filan several republican lawmakers and
members of the national rifle
association that new laws will expand
gun rights for texans the first law he
signed is what was being called the
constitutional carry bill which gets rid
of the licensing and training
requirement for texans who are 21 years
or older to carry a pistol those who
believe and support second amendment
rights we support the right of every
law-abiding american to be able to have
a weapon to defend themselves jesus
christ does any texas lawmaker actually
care about human life don't answer that
the sad truth is there have been eight
mass shootings in texas over the past 13
years all while lawmakers have steadily
loosened restrictions on carrying
firearms marjory taylor green and every
other deplorable republican want to
point fingers and blame others like
they're just playing a game of clue i'm
sorry to ruin the game but it was not
professor woke in the library with crt
it was the gun it's always been the
[ __ ] gun republicans love to blame
mental illness for mass shootings so if
it's such a problem like they say it is
then why haven't they done anything to
care for those suffering if it's such a
problem why did trump make it easier for
those with mental illness to get guns
when he rolled back an obama era
regulation if it's such a problem why
didn't they say no i'll tell you why
it's because republicans don't care
about you or anyone else so when exactly
will republicans start carrying 500 mass
shootings per year 800 a thousand how
many more innocent lives have to die
because of some weird fetish that
republicans have with guns ninety
percent of americans support background
checks on gun purchases but republican
politicians they're holding our country
hostage at gunpoint we are tired of
waiting we need to vote these
politicians out of office because if we
don't they will continue to send their
empty thoughts and prayers and happily
take donations from the nra and speak at
their conventions just days after a mass
shooting where children were murdered
the time for gun reform is past due we
need to stand up and make our voices
heard a great example of this is when
beta o'rourke confronted greg abbott at
his conference for the uvalde mass
shooting excuse me
excuse me sit down you're out of you're
out of line and an embarrassment
next shooting is right now and you're
doing nothing no he needs to give his
ass out here this isn't the place to
talk to him this is totally
so i leave you with this in a world of
greg abbott's
be a better or work
[Music]
finally done
boom
sanchez that was done see i was i tried
he he kept trying to go back and forth
with the name of this segment
and he settled on what was i wanted it
to be dirty sanchez but he he totally
was dodging me on the name dirty sanchez
but um you know i might be saving that
name for oh different something else
okay different product no no that's okay
yeah yeah yeah i just i just thought
that might you know that might
that might might be a you know a good uh
flavor for this segment but i
settled i think you settled on the right
name here right right yeah you know this
you touched on so much stuff in this
segment of videos that we're gonna watch
here because there was so much stuff
from the nra convention i don't know if
you've seen this um from lauren windsor
and i think she's uh posting an update
but she actually worked her way in
here's a picture of her and her friend
here who worked their way into the
convention she says ted cruz wants every
school in america to operate with a
single point of entry every day well at
nra and secret service couldn't do it
for one afternoon to protect trump a
friend and i walked into an unlocked
side door no screening passed an officer
into the reserved seating area
whoops so just just showing just showing
right there um how the one door theory
that is all nonsense it's all nonsense
you know it's crazy because
um
when we heard that they went through the
back door and ted cruz first started
saying the stupid [ __ ] right yeah um
he he
he starts talking about the back door
and i said that day that it was probably
propped open right like i i knew i knew
that door had to be locked like that's
procedure in most elementary schools
across the country the back door
is locked and the reason why is because
of all the [ __ ] mass shootings that
we have to keep these children safe
right and of course their solution that
the nra is just to [ __ ] turn their
turn our schools not just into locked
schools and locked buildings but prisons
turn them into [ __ ] prisons is what
they want to do they want to lock the
kids into the building to keep them safe
because
you know there's a bunch of dudes out
there that just have boners for guns
which i mean [ __ ] that's the thing
and i'll talk about it in the next video
that i make uh which i hope will come
out tomorrow on the speech that trump
gave at the nra convention but like in
there
you know they
beat down the whole idea they're like we
gotta harden schools we gotta harden
schools well you look at
you look at texas you valde like other
schools as well we've been harding in
schools with tons of funding you've got
40 percent of the city's budget going to
uh for uvalde going to the police you've
got billions
going you know to different programs
that they've been pushing since parkland
about hardening schools hardening
schools well here's the thing you harden
these schools and yet somebody with an
ar-15 was still able
to [ __ ] kill kids
so the whole idea that we have to harden
schools and we need to build high walls
and we need barbed wire and one point of
entry and security and technology that
deters anyone from coming in you
literally want to build a prison and
that is what trump is suggesting
and
it doesn't work it doesn't work right
right here here at the nra here's just a
little clip he explained gabe he
explains to the
audience how doors work here in this
clip it is
it is riveting [ __ ] here
listen to the
grandpa [ __ ] here explain how
doors and locks work riveting stuff
so important
in addition classroom doors should be
hardened to make them lockable from the
inside and closed to intruders
from the outside
thank god he knows how a door works with
a lock oh my god what would we do
without him
this is really [ __ ] stupid oh god
this i mean this is the guy that
continues the guy that you know ran
the country from 2017 to 2020
uh this was the dude who wanted to nuke
a hurricane
this is the guy
that was eating paper and trying to
flush documents down the toilet so it
should come as no surprise to anyone
that he's also the same guy that
probably just realized how a door works
right right it opens up this way that
way maybe sometimes the door swings both
ways oh my god are you kidding me
double-sided hinge you can't do that
you can't do that how does how does a
lock work gabe if you lock it from the
inside does that mean people from the
outside can't commit this is really
[ __ ] boneheaded [ __ ] just like the
nra itself they told this [ __ ] event
and if you look here this is a goddamn
sign in the front of the building of
[ __ ] you can't bring in you're banned
you're canceled from bringing this stuff
in aerosols ammunition backpacks i don't
know bulletproof or not
bags larger than 18 by 13x7 drones or
other unmanned aircraft system
firearms okay this is the nra this is
where the this is the [ __ ] place
where they claim more guns equals more
safety and you're not allowed to bring a
[ __ ] firearm into this place okay
you can't bring a loaded firearm into
this place they also do not want you to
have glass thermal or metal containers
uh gun parts holsters or magazines i'm
guessing it's uh
gun magazines not ammo magazines not
just like playboys i don't know maybe
yeah well it could be like it could be
like gun like
mega
oh oh yeah i'm not really sure they
don't want you to bring knives either
because they you know they always have
the argument well if we just get rid of
guns
then they would just mass murder people
with knives so they're terrified of nice
so it's not surprising it's not
surprising that they would ban knives
from the nra event laser pointers mace
pepper spray the biggest one i think on
the list which is the scariest [ __ ]
one on the list selfie sticks these
[ __ ] selfie sticks man running around
[ __ ] killing people this is just
crazy man we have to ban and get rid of
these back doors and these [ __ ]
selfie sticks these selfie sticks are
going to kill millions of americans
they're probably going to sneak into
[ __ ] schools gabe in the propped open
back door and murder 19 children in
texas these [ __ ] selfie sticks is
what we got to worry about signs
toy guns yeah
okay
there is a george carlin clip and i'm
going to play you a clip about wayne
lape because we're gonna talk about
wayne lape here oh yeah
but there is a clip from george carlin
way back in the day way back in the day
when when these toy guns were starting
to look more and more real these toy
manufacturers were making them look real
and you know they they eventually put
like an orange or a red cap on the front
of it yeah so which you could also take
off or paint right yeah yeah either way
but george garland had a great clip he
said they're gonna ban toy guns and keep
the [ __ ] real ones so here they're
banning real guns and toy guns at the
nra convention and then the best
weapons of any kind i don't know i like
nunchucks i don't know what that
ninja stars you can't bring ninja stars
into a man if you're making a paper
airplane or you're making anything that
has a pointy end to it
that could be directed at me
that [ __ ] is banned dude right right
that [ __ ] is cancelled
cancel culture right here all over the
nra sign here and at the very bottom it
says there is no storage available for
firearms so like they're like you can't
bring it in and even if you try we won't
even store it for you right there's no
storage available of course might just
touch put this
this picture on here
this really is um hypocrisy a disgrace
greatest course it's not [ __ ]
surprising
from these pieces of [ __ ] it's it's not
surprising that this is coming from the
nra and the nra convention like i said
we're going to look at a video of
wayne lapayer
now we're going to go back to ted cruz
because they kind of circle back around
him because you talk about him also in
your video you just talk about so much
in your video but i want to show this um
this sign that the good liars put up
because the clip i'm going to show you
where they talk directly to wayne
lapierre it is the good lighters and the
good liars posted this sign they put
they said they put notice no firearms
allowed inside the nra event because
guns are dangerous
and we are massive hypocrites
the good liars never
they never seem to fail gabe right never
like which is also funny because these
people and i'll and i'll i'll mention um
uh i will i will probably mention this
in the video but like trump
talks about gun-free zones and he says
gun-free zones actually leads
to more mass shootings right so you've
got this event at the nra which is like
no guns allowed you know gun free zone
it's a gun-free zone
uh but also
it's gonna bring in more shootings i
mean you look at you know laura windsor
and she's able to walk through side door
with no security so it's like maybe
maybe he's onto something but he's
actually not gun-free zones the whole
thing is based on a study from years ago
where they're basically cherry-picking
data
and every town did
their own research and found out that it
was much much lower it was like
10 percent or lower as opposed to
that the nra and these gun nuts would
cherry pick and the manufacturers would
cherry pick data oh yeah and have a
study that makes sure that they say yeah
more guns equals more safety right
and then they send their thoughts and
prayers right when this when this [ __ ]
happens which is um kind of the aim here
this is a q a session here at the nra
annual gathering in houston texas where
they cheered the slaughtering of 19
children trump even danced he danced he
really had a fun time you know uh
memorializing the the stack of dead
bodies that happened in uvalde he was
dancing he was so excited about it yeah
just dancing on the graves that's right
what the [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
disgusting vile piece of [ __ ] but here
you see the uh the panel here wayne
lopez sitting here but let's watch let's
watch with jason from the good liars um
the commentary and the he thanks wayne
lapierre here and it's beautiful and
what the best part about it gabe is at
the very end so stay at the very end
here and uh
so i have to say thank you
[Applause]
the chair recognizes the gentleman that
microphone 1a
thank you um my name is jason
and i'm from west palm beach florida and
i would like to say
that i
am sick and tired of the left-wing media
and frankly people in this room today
spreading misinformation about wayne
lapierre
whenever there's a mass shooting
they all say that wayne lapierre isn't
doing enough to stop these mass
shootings and even implying that wayne
lapierre has played a part in making it
easier for these shooters
to get guns to get weapons
you heard it after las vegas you heard
it after pulse nightclub in orlando
you heard it after columbine
you you heard it after parkland you
heard it after virginia tech
you heard it after sandy hook you heard
it after el paso you heard it after
buffalo you kept hearing that wayne
lapierre isn't doing enough and frankly
that's not true
the nra under wayne lapierre's
leadership
has provided
thoughts
and prayers
to the victims and their families
and and maybe these mass shootings would
stop happening
if we all
thought a little bit more
and we pray
a little bit
more i'm asking everyone in this room
to think
to pray
give your thoughts
and your prayers
and your thoughts and your prayers
and your prayers and your thoughts and
if we give enough of these thoughts and
these prayers
these mass shootings
will stop so i want to thank you
wayne lapierre
for all your thoughts
and all your prayers
thank you
look at these people they're like yeah
they're like yeah baby thoughts and
prayers they're clapping they're having
a good time it's too easy
like i mean it's a it's a great
it's a great tactic obviously to call it
man the goof though on them oh yeah and
not one of the [ __ ] in the room
even caught it like they didn't even
catch it they didn't i know i know well
that's the thing like you have to you
know you have to call out the [ __ ]
while wrapping it up in something nice
so you're like oh yeah you know people
say he didn't do enough after you know
listing off every single one right and
trying to be like people say didn't do
enough and i say that's
[ __ ] right it's [ __ ] because he
sent thoughts and prayers which
obviously is what he did and what he
continued to do and the republican party
continued to do over and over again
but
he called it like he was like here's
this
[ __ ] flaming turd right but
i'm gonna throw some [ __ ] sprinkles
on it
so that it maybe some of you get the
sarcasm that's here and some of you
don't
and the ones that don't are gonna
[ __ ] eat it up like it's you know uh
some peach treat you know dessert i
don't know
but
it's one of those things where it's so
beautiful and so easy to do and it's so
predictable right they'll just be like
yeah because he yeah he knew he knew all
he had to do is say thoughts and prayers
a thousand times right which which
honestly the gag is is that that doesn't
do [ __ ] that's the whole point the whole
point is it doesn't do [ __ ] and they're
like yeah that does all kinds of that
make sure we still have these events
right those words make sure we have
these events like what they're cheering
um
wayne lapierre has been
part of the nra for a long time uh so
long in fact that george garland did a
little bit about him and uh he includes
charlton heston because uh wayne
lapierre was kind of the head guy and
then
they discovered
that wasn't good enough so they put
charlton heston um who was a famous
actor and head of the internet you know
he famously held the gun out gun up and
he said buy this from my gold dead hands
yeah and charlton hessen did yeah that's
a famous little bit but um george
garland here the great george carlin and
and forgive me are you out there on
youtube if we have to cut the sound out
here it's because youtube and the
copyright but i want to play it for us
man i want to play well them sons of
them deep state
but um i want to play this anyways
because
um this is over 20 years ago and this
was george carlin's little take on wayne
lapierre speaking of mindless hollywood
[ __ ]
before charlton heston became president
of these [ __ ] lunatics in the nra
they had a different guy
and a different guy he's still one of
their major spokesman his name is wayne
lapierre
what kind of a name for a gun nut is
wayne
lapierre it sound a little fruity to you
hi i'm wayne i'm a gun person
bang bang
[Applause]
you know what this prick's name ought to
be biff webster
spud crowley a man's name chuck stake
so obviously um george carlin is doing
the goof a little a little differently
than what jason did it the goof that
charlton hessen is he's making fun of
their manhood right he's making fun of
these gun nuts manhood by attacking
wayne lapierre that is their leader um
and because that truly is what this
whole gun thing is about right it's the
tanning of your balls the tucker carlson
type thing um this picture really
gives it a great explanation um this
woman looking down this man's pants and
says well that explains the assault
rifles you know it's the little dick
syndrome the little dick energy that
happens with
um speaking of a little dick energy
maybe that's where i get my um my
transitions from ms carlin i don't know
that maybe
now here's here's arkansas governor
ashton
asha hutchinson and uh he's on face the
nation why face the nation let him go on
and on and on and gaslight america about
this but i have a couple clips of this
[ __ ] i want to play and uh
totally uh
just beat him to death with my words i
think a lot of people would agree with
many of the things you just said but
then they would ask why can't we talk
about the weapon
i understand a lot of people may want a
long gun to go hunting but then there's
this ar-15 style weapon
semi-automatic not that good for hunting
um
the bullets travel three times the speed
of sound they literally blow bodies
apart that's what was used in buffalo
was used in sandy hook it was used in
uvalde why not raise the minimum age of
purchase to 21 from 18.
well you've seen some states actually do
that right and you've seen it in florida
you've seen it in california in
california the restriction was held as
unconstitutional so there are some
constitutional challenges to that
ultimately i think the supreme court is
going to give us guidance on it but you
look at ar-15 but you would endorse that
well each one has to have wait for it
no i want to give a little bit more
history ar-15s were around for 40 years
before they were ever used in any type
of mass
killing or attack
and the reason why
and he
he skips the facts here
is because the amount that were
manufactured and sold
what in the what how in the [ __ ] can't
we
how can't we
why can't she just say all right let's
not stop because i'm going to show you
i'm going to show you a video of jim
acosta on cnn go telling an nra board
member not shut the [ __ ] up i'm you're
not gonna just spew that lies here yeah
this type of response and the fact that
you let it kind of happen is like
[ __ ] you know i feel like we should
be better we should follow like sky news
jim acosta that is the the example we
should follow in terms of going again
and again and again and following up
with questions to actually prove the
point and actually you know shoot down
no pun intended or maybe pun intended
the actual [ __ ] that they're
spreading here right but
uh
when you look at someone like this this
reminds me of the similar response that
uh you know manchin gave where he said
listen i will do
anything anything at all to stop this
violence from happening okay great well
in order to do that we need to get rid
of the filibuster stubby can pass this
sorry guys can't do that i'll do
anything but it won't do that right so
it's just like this when he knew he
wouldn't do that right so that's the
whole gig here that's the that's it's
the back door thing that's the back door
thing anything to blame anything but the
[ __ ] gun look let's stop talking
about the gun stop talking about gun
let's look look there's a door it was a
teacher's fault you know and they're
like listen there's that little block
triangle that opens the door that's the
real problem we got to stop making these
door stoppers okay tony because they're
getting out of control right and sooner
or later they're gonna kill random
people well i mean that's that's the the
fact of the matter is is the door lobby
because i guarantee you there is a door
lobby oh there's a big door lobby right
but it doesn't pay as well as the gun
lobby right and that's why you have
[ __ ] like this saying [ __ ] like he's
gonna say let's listen and so it is
about the human heart it is about
identifying uh the culprits and going
after them uh and you i think it is a
discussion you can have i come down on
the point that that's not going to be
the solution
and it's going to cause more harm than
good uh in arkansas for example as you
pointed out the long rifles uh we
distinguish those and those you can
acquire at 18 because we hunt with those
we uh it's a culture that we start when
we're 14 or 15 here in arkansas and and
so that's important part of it and it's
a step uh to go to the ar-15s and how
you draft laws that would distinguish
those that'll be a part of the
discussion i come down i don't think
that's a solution and we shouldn't focus
on that
and again this idea that she can't stop
him and say whoa whoa whoa on the
culture thing don't you think that's
part of the don't you think that's part
of the problem governor you [ __ ]
idiot how about that being part of the
problem yeah dumb [ __ ] like yeah
the culture the culture and how many
people need a gun and an example of this
actually i'll get i'll send you the
tweet is matt gates
trying to excuse the use of an ar-15 to
hunt hogs bro yeah well yeah gabe we
gotta tear them apart them hogs apart
listen this is all [ __ ] nonsense
i i grew up with hunting rifles in the
house hunting rifles that were used for
[ __ ] hunting
there are there are campaign after
campaign videos of these [ __ ] psychos
with these goddamn weapons of war saying
they're not for hunting the second
amendment isn't for hunting it's for
killing politicians that's what they're
saying that's it's for a tyrannical
government that's they don't give a [ __ ]
about killing animals that's all
nonsense right they want to be able to
murder mass groups of people that's what
they want that's what the [ __ ]
weapons are designed to do jesus christ
they say it in the [ __ ] commercials
for the guns and the ants for the guns
themselves is that the idea is to kill
as many people as [ __ ] possible and
create as much damage as possible but
let's forget about the guns for a second
gabe because we got we got to talk about
back doors here
there was an armed officer uh assigned
to the elementary school in uvalde um
good guy with the gun
police force response
where they did not good guys
who was carrying an ar-15
in buffalo the armed guard who was at
that grocery store confronted the
shooter but was killed in parkland
florida there was an armed officer on
site who did not intervene doesn't this
show that this is an insufficient
solution to the problem you can't talk
about good guys and bad guys because it
has the word gun
right what you got to do is focus on
something that has nothing to do with
the guns listen to what the great
governor arkansas says here
well it certainly shows that you have to
have multiple layers of security to
protect the children
and there's also the factor of human
error and that's the reason that you've
got to have different layers you can't
rely upon just one technique
school safety is something that we all
have to focus on coming out of the
incredible tragedy that we see in uvalde
we have to look at how we can better
secure our schools
and it is about the single point of
entry that
by
blocking it open allowed the gunman to
come in it is about i want to point out
here these vile [ __ ] are
blaming blaming a teacher for propping
open a door right think about this for a
second propping open a [ __ ] door
they're going to blame the 19 murders
of those children on the teacher who
propped open the [ __ ] door not not
the [ __ ] governor who signed a bill
to make sure that this crazy ass
[ __ ] could get these guns as
soon as he turned the minute he turned
18 without question without question
no training no [ __ ] nothing nothing like
matt said earlier you want nothing
and this [ __ ] is gonna regulate
teachers when and they can and cannot
open doors that's what they're saying
they're saying we can give weapons to
anyone
because we want the profit for the gun
but we can ha we cannot have teachers
we cannot have teachers
opening doors when they're not supposed
to be open we have to have door control
we have to regulate these [ __ ]
teachers to make sure they're not there
number one they're sounding up mind we
got to do a background check on them
they got to have a college education
they have to have a [ __ ] certificate
to [ __ ] teach
but they also need training on when they
can and when they can't prop open what
door what door they can't
they have to have proper training gabe
and it just is not enough to [ __ ]
make sure that they have college
educated certified continuing education
every single [ __ ] year it's not
enough we have to make sure
with the big government
that these doors have proper training
with those teachers this is [ __ ]
ridiculous absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous
that we even have to go through the
motions of this dumb vile stupid [ __ ]
that they're gonna blame a teacher for
propping open a door this is [ __ ]
stupid i mean it pushes it pushes the
idea that teachers are no
no more than a guard at a prison right
if you're already if you're already
building up this school to be you know
quote unquote fort knox one entry you've
got high walls you've got technology to
deter anyone with a weapon coming in and
then you say teachers you also have a
gun but also i need you to run the halls
or rather roam the halls on your shift
make sure the doors are locked you don't
open any doors unless you know you're
instructed to you are a guard you are
teaching it sounds very like um i don't
know of like a fascist way to teach
right way to control you know it's
almost like they're trying to make their
own kind of
you know listen here listen here he goes
on the [ __ ] he's he's on the teacher
bandwagon here and listen to what he
says the mental health issues where of
course we have to do better to you don't
[ __ ] support mental health
or potentially a mass killer uh you've
got to have our private sector internet
providers to do better we got to
regulate the internet to identify
these kind of dangerous violent
communications much quicker and then of
course we have to be able to train our
officers properly
i don't we're going to have to learn a
lot more facts as to some of the things
that happen in uvalde let's be patient
let's learn from them but we can't give
up on our most precious resource in
protecting our children and i couldn't i
i couldn't remember if he talked about
arming the teachers or the police
officers but he said the police officers
here but i was talking to a teacher
friend of mine this weekend
and he was and you know it i've had this
discussion with him before about army
teachers he is a teacher he's been for
he's been for many many years now he's
been a teacher
and this is a really good idea
let me let me explain it to you gabe why
this arming teachers of course i'm being
sarcastic here's such a great [ __ ]
idea okay just imagine a scenario okay
where you're in you went to a high
school or a middle school or an
elementary school it doesn't really
matter right
because really the idea of making sure
that every single teacher is a good guy
with a gun
makes a lot of sense they're good guys
they're teachers they have guns right
because a good guy with a gun never
turns into a bad guy with a gun never
ever ever a good guy never turns into a
bad guy
now what let me let me give you a
scenario here where a good guy would not
do a bad guy thing only a good guy thing
let's say we have a teacher who's i
don't know slips through the cracks
has some mental illness maybe has a
scuffle
with one of the other teachers in the
school i don't know maybe just maybe
that could happen
and let's say we're at lunch time and
that other teacher's in the cafeteria
with the students all the students and
this good guy with a gun which is the
other teacher right that had a scuffle
he's a he's a good guy with a gun he's a
good guy don't forget that gabe he's the
good guy yeah no you told me he's a good
guy so i believe it he's got a gun in
his desk in a safe locked safely away
with a code so the kids can't get it
okay this is this is their scenario this
is what they want for our children
now this teacher this good guy goes to
his safe
and gets his gun he has the code to the
safe he has to because what if a bad guy
with a gun would enter the school he has
to be able to get to his good god gun
right right so the good guy teacher gets
his good guy gun gabe
he's got his good guy gun now the bad
guy the bad guy is the teacher in the
cafeteria without the gun
maybe maybe that teacher in the
cafeteria schlubbed his wife maybe he
was trying to get his girlfriend i don't
know maybe they just had an argument in
the teacher's life
who knows about gun control it could
happen
now the good guy with the gun starts to
walk down to the cafeteria to go
confront the bad guy
without the gun okay there's also a lot
of bad guy students in the cafeteria too
you know these bad guys are kind of
bystanders sometimes right right
especially with these good guys with
these guns these good guys with these
guns we got to give them enough room to
operate they're good guys they're good
guys and a good guy never turns into a
bad guy with a gun
now let's just say that this good guy
with a gun
who we've trained obviously
and we've given the money and we've
given the uh everything that this good
guy needs
to know how to execute
a bad guy
with or without a gun
now he goes down to the cafeteria to
confront the bad guy the remember he's
still a good guy with the gun
and he becomes a bad guy with a gun and
not only does he become a bad guy with a
gun maybe he just slings a few bullets
and gets a few innocent bystander bad
guys you know those little ones children
oopsies thing like that what right that
is a scenario that no one is talking
about
no one would say that out loud
other than me maybe because listen this
good guy bad guy [ __ ] and i think you're
gonna do it in one of your what was that
this week is try to get rid of this
fallacy right of this good guy bad guy
stuff because it is really [ __ ]
stupid yep it's really [ __ ] dumb
there is no good guy there is no bad
guys there's just guys
with guns yeah that's all it is i mean
we saw in real time
right listen the the the kid with the
[ __ ] gun that killed the 19 children
and the two teachers in uvalde was the
good guy with the gun his grandmother
was was the bad guy his grandmother was
the bad guy and he was so mad at his
grandmother being the bad guy that he
had to go get the other bad guys too
this is just it's absolutely bonkers
it's bat [ __ ] crazy i can't even tell
you how [ __ ] pissed off i am that
they even use this [ __ ] anymore
but really it is starting
um it is really starting to un
unfold and it really is starting to
not be
easy to make this argument good guy bad
guy the argument's starting to fall
apart this is a picture of daniel
defense
um this is where he bought the gun from
yeah yeah daniel defense uh bought the
gun for this child and he's got it on
his lap and fantastic no i'm saying this
is where this is where the uh
that's why this is also
i was watching a press conference um
and it was at the white house and they
were talking about how this
this company also received a
3.13 million dollar uh ppp loan
and so there was a question of like
would they you know would the white
house try to take that money back in any
way
but you know another organization who oh
god forbid uh we don't sell enough guns
yeah we need
we need more funding and loans
to buy more guns
for my business
that ends up giving the gun
to the kid who shot 19 kids and two
teachers
well i mean again this more of this i
[ __ ] said last week
that they're gonna [ __ ] have baby
style weapons and they already do yeah
and that's gonna be i mean i watched a
video the other day i watched a video
the other day on on twitter i think it
was and it was this person that was
talking to a child
who she was asking i'll see if i can
find it it's [ __ ] they want to talk
about indoctrinating kids with crt and
left left-wing ideas and all this stuff
it's like no no when you're when you're
having an interview with a small child
and you're asking him
how to
uh
load a gun how to change out the
magazine on an assault rifle
or or any gun
when you know that
that child
cannot even bear the recoil
of the gun that they're shooting
right let alone have the emotional
maturity
to make the decision to shoot that gun
in a situation that calls for it because
like i said
and they're they're making that scenario
it's not like right or never existed
they're not teaching the kid how to hunt
or to target practice they're saying
they're going to be prepared to protect
their family or some [ __ ] some crazy ass
delusional lunatic type stuff and
speaking seeing a lunatic look at this
[ __ ] lunatic here shannon watts um
posted this on her instagram that's
where i pulled this from i don't know
who the credit is it's a different
person that took the picture so go check
out shannon's instagram to figure out
the uh the credit i i didn't have that
here um but this person has protect kids
not guns and look at this old man with
the of course you know desecrating the
american flag by making into shirt which
i don't have a problem with i think you
should desecrate the american flag as
much as you possibly can that's your
right in this country you have the right
to do that that is your liberty you can
speak out you can kneel for the flag and
during the anthem you [ __ ] but this guy
desecrates the flag by making a nice
little grandpa style shirt here but he's
got his [ __ ] fingers in his ears
because he just can't hear
he just can't hear what the protesters
are saying you know it gave the old here
are no evil see no evil speak no evil
and there will be no evil
um obviously grandpa dumb [ __ ] here
doesn't realize just covering years
doesn't fix
the problem it doesn't fix the problem
it doesn't go away
and that was the nra event here is um
here's a nice little video too from um
uh jess jesse piper
of missouri um
she ran for a congressional seat this is
a fantastic video here if you see this
picture here this is um
sorry the sound
this is the uh the sound is hilarious
here but this is the the
picture of the convention and it's it
appears to be a little empty game it
appears to be just a tad empty but then
it shows
it looks pretty empty when we were
watching the good live video yes it was
it's it's empty yeah it's fact no one
likes no one wants to go to this [ __ ]
thing besides the people who want to
protest it wait till the end because
then you'll see the protest
[Music]
[Music]
of course we know that that there was a
big huge rally and a big protest of the
nra convention uh beto spoke at it now i
don't really have uh too many clips of
that but i do have a clip here uh
outside the the rally with one of the
nra board members and cnn jim acosta um
just absolutely rails on this son of a
[ __ ] and takes him to task takes him to
task um i want to bring in
here this thing thanks for the super
sticker anyone who's been in the super
chat today sorry we're trying to go
faster i got a lot of video i want to
get to
yeah so a lot happened over the weekend
whoosh it's full monday it's full money
i'm glad i'm glad we we went ahead and
did this on memorial day because man our
plate would be really full tomorrow yeah
if we did i mean tomorrow we've got an
interview
yeah that's right that's right and i'm
gonna play that video i'm gonna play
that video yeah here right after this
and to show the hypocrisy and how their
message is being destroyed but um this
is more of this [ __ ] ar-15 you know
shooting hogs type [ __ ] let's listen
with these shootings it keeps coming
back to the uh it keeps coming back to
the ar-15 and similar models why do
people need an ar-15 anyway
you know it's just a semi-automatic
rifle i mean you know if you want to be
prejudiced about the way it looks
but uh i was aware of what happened in
the 94 uh semi-automatic firearms ban
and there were rifles of similar
function that just didn't look as ugly
they weren't black guns like a mini 14
ruger mini 14. and of course the ruger
mini 14 was appropriate and the ar-15
was not if it had a bainet lug
or a vertical rear grip
i do want to ask you about the assault
weapons man but you know on the ar-15
how how is it that an 18 year old can
buy an ar-15 style rifle and have 1600
rounds of ammo with them like we saw in
uvalde
well it's he did not have any prior
convictions he didn't have any prior
issues that would have kept him from
purchasing one it's my understanding
from the news that he purchased it
through a firearms dealer he passed the
background check because he didn't have
any prior convictions right but should
an 18 year old have an ar that's how he
bought it should an a should an 18 year
old have an ar-15
what's he going to do i don't know 18
year old have one in the
army so they had military they had
military training in the army this 18
year old and yuvali did not have
military training he turned 18 and he
went out watch this game
and the fact is that these kinds of
issues are far more complicated than
whether we remove did he call him ed
yeah i don't know i don't know but did
you notice when he when he threw that
yeah they do have him in the military
and there's this thing called military
like that's the whole point
is that
they do
months and months of training yeah you
[ __ ] bonehead and as soon as he
realizes no one's ever no one's ever
slung that argument at me before he just
completely oh [ __ ]
i mean he just he he literally just has
a huge brain fart there more like a
brain shark probably yeah but listen
listen to the [ __ ] i don't know what
this mr magoo looking [ __ ] here
i don't know let's let's finish move
something from the public
these issues in criminogenics you can't
buy a beer if you're 18 you can't buy
crime are more complicated than than the
easy answer
do you want to know why politicians
seems to go to gun control because it
doesn't cost them any money no jesus
christ
that's that's the it costs the
manufacturers money gabe
it costs them money if you do gun
control and that is something that we
can't do and we can't that's why
politicians always go to gun control
because it doesn't cost them any money
right it doesn't cost them any money
here's another clip um
here of the of the interview this is a
great one here too
uh judge uh thank you for being with us
uh for years your group has blocked
new gun safety laws and push for the
most relaxed rules possible on firearms
isn't some of this blood
on the nra's hands
well let me first say jim thanks for
being having me on the show i want to
tell you that i really don't believe the
supposition of your questions accurate i
know that while i'm not somewhat maybe
not i followed the issue closely and
that the nra and other organizations
even myself as a state senator in kansas
have worked to tighten the laws i think
watch this important to understand no no
no sir
i hope i hope you understand i'm gonna
have to cut you off uh when you start
saying things that that just aren't true
thank you
rules that that's just not the case
[Music]
thank you jim acosta for for uh uh
telling him to go [ __ ] himself no you
just can't say whatever you want on my
[ __ ] show dude
like what in the [ __ ] this is not
something where you can just say
whatever you want
we're gonna we're gonna tell facts here
and tell the [ __ ] truth this is this
is exactly the way the media should do
it exactly the way that they should have
handled um
what's his [ __ ] name the the governor
hutchinson the governor of
of arkansas
and that's exactly the way they should
i've got a i've got a video too
of um the one i was showing you of the
kid reloading i think this is from like
2018
um because i don't want to share the the
per the the person who was sharing this
video
which is kendall jones
um she's another one of those like you
know goes out and hunts exotic animals
like [ __ ] um
so i'm not gonna share her profile but
i'm gonna share the video
that uh she was promoting
and i think it might have recently
got gone viral again okay go ahead and
you play it on your end there yeah yeah
what's your name
maverick
that is awesome how old are you maverick
he is four years old show me what you do
with the gun
do it again
[Music]
take the magazine out
oh can you put it back in
[Music]
yeah get it done
that is the definition of grooming
you're teaching you're teaching a little
bitty child that doesn't understand what
that what that piece of material is and
you're acting like it's a [ __ ] toy
you
ding it yeah you want to you want a band
like you said you want to ban the toy
guns about the real guns and like you
look at this kid this kid that gun is
the size
of that shot like that gun is probably
taller than that child right meanwhile
he's like loading and unloading it
shooting changing out the magazine
putting the magazine in take it loading
unloading shooting like
again you know very easy to do when it's
on a [ __ ] shelf right right but
oh yeah sure let's give that gun to a
kid right that thing would probably
[ __ ] take off the shoulder of that
child right well here's the thing is in
rural america there is such thing as
teaching in the nra at one point in its
history at one point in its history not
its origination but at one point in its
history it was about teaching rural kids
gun safety at one point for a brief
moment before they really started to
make to bastardize the second amendment
as if the militia was every single
american not the state militias but at
one moment they were they were an
organization that taught gun safety to
rule kids and when i was a kid i was
a little bitty kid i was taught not to
touch the gun right you're not to touch
the gun because you can't handle it
you're not you're not big enough to
handle the gun right you just can't
handle the gun and then you were taught
how to use the gun and how not to use
the gun how to store the gun how to load
the gun
in case you needed to use the gun
but you were not you were not you were
not taught
this weird ass delusional stuff as if
this little bitty kid is gonna find this
gun in the closet right and have it as a
play toy this is [ __ ] weird and gross
and like you think that a child you know
like i said in the video like a good guy
with the gun is going to be stopped by
or like you know or a bad guy with the
gun is the only thing i can stop a bad
guy with a gun is a a good child with a
gun right with a with a [ __ ] you're
gonna you're gonna honestly tell me that
you believe that this child is gonna get
this rifle out of what let's assume that
it's in a safe location like it's in a
safe in a closet somewhere in your
parent's bedroom you're gonna assume
that this child can go to the door
turn the knob open the door
reach up on a stool
punch the code in open the sit move the
stool
open the safe
get the gun
get the ammunition
load the gun and then drag that gun over
to shoot this person that was a bad guy
with the gun oh [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] it's it's bonkers batshit crazy
speaking of bonkers batshit crazy you've
seen ted cruz say some crazy [ __ ] this
weekend
crazy [ __ ] but the best ted cruz video
that came out of there's a couple of
them right one of the best ted cruz
videos that came out this weekend
is uh his name is benjamin right is it
uh is it yeah benjamin hernandez
benjamin hernandez um and we're gonna
have i think we're gonna have benjamin
on tomorrow um to talk about this video
he's coming on the show tomorrow
uh to talk about this video that we're
gonna show now i think this is the video
that they were taking is that correct
because there was some bystander video
yeah so there was the first one that got
released was from across the restaurant
right where people started heroes going
on and it was a snippet it was just a
yeah yeah because i think what happened
was this started happening and they're
like there's a confrontation and
someone's like oh [ __ ] someone's like
arguments had cruz and they started to
film it so we only caught part way
through the video maybe maybe maybe
people should just keep a a [ __ ]
camera on take care of it
someone's going to get i would honestly
just put a gopro on and just live
anywhere i knew that ted cruz was going
to be i would just live stream the inter
just just in case something were to
happen which most likely it would now
this is a fantastic model of
how to pressure these son of a [ __ ]
and if you notice in the video the first
one to put hands on someone is ted cruz
yeah physically touches the thing is he
does the same thing with the with the
reporter from sky news he puts hands on
and tries to
uh gaslight right and then also uh you
know kind of dismiss what they're saying
like i'm sorry you feel that way i'm
sorry you don't like american
exceptionalism you know right that's the
whole patriarchal touch right exactly
you're like i'm better than you right
you need to shut up now type thing watch
this video um this is fantastic how ted
cruz thinks he's gonna because ted cruz
loves to take selfies here oh yeah but
he doesn't like to hear the truth let's
watch
okay you ready yeah okay hold on
all right one now i want to point out um
if you're unaware
um
the the guy
who looks like a schlub that that the
blob yeah the blob that is great
for a human being right right
man he really needs to [ __ ] learn he
needs to watch a few youtube videos on
on beard trimming and [ __ ] this is
[ __ ] ridiculous but the other the
other gentleman standing here this is
benjamin hernandez who is about to
talk to
ted cruz
about taking blood money from the
internet let's listen
two
he wants you to listen to him
[Music]
you know what what up
it is harder it is harder
when there are more guns to stop gun
violence
it is not ignorant
we are in this country and there are
guns everywhere
why
when 19 children died 19 children died
as on your hands that is on your hands
right through that one turn
so yeah benjamin will be on joining us
tomorrow to tell his side of the story
here um obviously you see the video but
um
it is uh
it's one of those things that
you know you would hope because uh
benjamin is out of the i think he's out
of the houston area in texas and so you
know i look at this and you know he
gun control and reform is something
that's you know definitely one of his
kind of pillars that he believes in
and when you've got representatives or
you know lawmakers whoever like ted cruz
i mean like we've seen it we saw last
week we'll see it again this week we saw
in the video just now
his his ability to
completely dismiss
another person
and say your thoughts aren't valid
and i don't really care what you have to
say because what i'm going to say is
that i'm right and you're wrong and i'm
in control and you're not
and
you are just a nuisance to the public
right now
and that's what ted cruz does to anyone
who disagrees with them anyone who
actually brings facts anyone who
actually corrects him and says well
actually you're wrong on this because of
xyz you know anyone who calls him out
for the [ __ ] his responsibility or
the
the accountability that should be had on
these politicians like ted cruz who have
who have passed bills and supported you
know pro second amendment agenda
you know you've got people like benjamin
hernandez which i feel like you know
should should be doing more of this just
like beto they should be calling these
people out they should be i don't you
know some people and this healing too
some people get really upset like it
should be done in a public setting not
in a private setting
at this point i don't [ __ ] care
call them out
call them out call them out right you
got extra protection for scotus when
people are picking on the public
sidewalk outside the house and people
say you know what that's just in poor
taste you shouldn't do that right
you shouldn't uh you shouldn't uh uh
um
you shouldn't go into someone's
restaurant and and kind of disrupt their
dinner well you know what
i'm sure that you know the parents
didn't want you to disrupt their dinner
by by letting some person kill their
children that's right maybe maybe ted
cruz should get off his [ __ ] ass and
realize what the actual problem is
here's one of the clips from some of the
[ __ ] that this this monster just
puked out of his vile mouth um at the
nra but here here's one where he's
blaming it he's blaming it on
he's blaming it on elites in
neighborhoods that are gated now
remember and i'm going to show you a
tweet from is this the video that he
also blames uh
there's
single parents and it's father father
just just just watch this one here
the elites
who dominate our culture
tell us that firearms
lie at the root of the problem
because they do by elites
i refer to some of the most powerful
politicians and their allies in the
media
the leaders of the largest corporations
and many of the most famous celebrities
this is a [ __ ] this [ __ ]
is a true
educated attorney
you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
this guy is the elite
gasps he went to ivy league he went to
princeton
undergrad he went to harvard to get wait
wait wait princeton princeton that's got
to be a community college right that's
not like yeah it's a very expensive
community college yeah very expensive
community you have to be part of a
certain community to go to like you have
to
you have to yeah you have to be kind of
the upper echelon of people to be
admitted into the school and then to go
to harvard
for a long time this is just [ __ ]
projection at its finest oh yeah at its
finest like i'm an elite and i'm going
to tell you what the [ __ ] you're going
to do
but it's the elites like me that it's
the fault of because they're talking
don't look at us elites don't look at
the elites that are making six figures
plus
because of lobbyists from the nra don't
don't don't look at the elites like
myself who were just paid to spit this
[ __ ] propaganda or wayne lapierre you
know that guy don't don't pay attention
who who used all
all your money the elites that we are
here at the nra the people who actually
get your money the elites that you that
you second-class citizen give us that's
literally what the nra is the nra runs
around humping votes getting donations
from these voters to make sure that the
elites wayne lapierre the gun
manufacturers have all the money all the
profit in the world you [ __ ]
boneheads and here he is puking this
[ __ ] up this piece of [ __ ]
and [ __ ] let's listen
and those who echo and amplify them
their resources are limitless
their megaphone is enormous
like yours and their voice
as he talks into a [ __ ] microphone
at the end
text and everyone else is suppressing
our voice man they're
and their power the people who are
elected in power
who who are trying to change these laws
you know like united states senators
elected in places like i don't know
texas jesus or or governors yeah
lieutenant governor attorney generals
places like
texas
be deafening
many of these same people make their
accusations from behind great bulwarks
of safety
from gated communities equipped with
private
closet pause it hold on hold on this
[ __ ] right here is going to talk
about a gated community and security
when he's at an nra convention where
they've already banned anything under
the [ __ ] sun that would resemble a
weapon
gabe selfie sticks are scary ass [ __ ]
man this guy
this guy wants to talk about how elites
use their megaphone
in a protected gated community
to speak down to others when this guy
is literally on a stage right speaking
into speakers or in a microphone on the
speakers out to an audience in a
convention hall that has been armed with
character but
yeah
plenty of plenty of room for the guns if
they wanted to let them in right but in
a gated community that bans
guns from entry or any sort of weapon
whether there's selfie sticks or numb
chucks or a toy gun with an orange tip
this guy wants to stand on stage and
speak down to everyone right
and say
i'm not the elite and this isn't a
megaphone and this itself is not a gated
community in which i am speaking on to
you on about oh my god
[ __ ] ridiculous this guy
security or at the very least
from safe and expensive neighborhoods
protected by high home prices
and low crime rates
what is ted cruz such people can afford
an indulgent ideology
afford an indulge
in ideology what the [ __ ] does that mean
you mean you mean the parents the
parents at the [ __ ] school that their
children were 19 sets of parents where
their children were gunned down you're
telling me
you're now now that
you're telling me that they're the ones
who can afford this ideology that hey
maybe we should do something this is
[ __ ] crazy and ridiculous of course
ted cruz posted that video gabe he's
like oh this is a really good clip yeah
this is a real that's how proud he was
and uh joaquin castro
of texas
um
he points out a really good at to our
last video that we showed a benjamin he
points out a really good fact here he
says after finishing this speech
or his speech this common man was
chauffeured
to the uptown sushi
in the wealthiest part of houston where
he was then
that restaurant he was at was called
uptown sushi in the wealthiest part of
houston and he was he was toted there by
car this [ __ ] absolute piece of
garbage trish
trish ted cruz's [ __ ] trash
oh i can't ted cruz if this is still
accurate ted cruz
lives in a 5 bedroom 3.5 bathroom house
that is estimated to be worth
2.1
million dollars
which he bought in 2011 for 1.5 million
dollars look listen it's a three-story 4
000 i'm sure it's a [ __ ] dump i'm
sure it's a [ __ ] dog man i'm sure
it's a i mean he left cancun when
electric went out and left his dog in
this dump so it's gotta be a [ __ ]
dump this guy has a net worth of four
million dollars
remember
four million dollars that's not that's
not a lead at all that's not it
you have to have at least at least 10
million
and go to at least six ivy league
schools not just two i mean also
remember his wife is a managing director
at goldman sachs
goldman sachs you can't convince me that
they're elite you get goldman
sachs tony speaking of elite white
trailer trash look at this guy boy look
at this [ __ ] guy
this guy oh my god there's so much i
haven't seen this video but i know it's
going to be a gentleman i know i'm going
to want to use it for a facetime video
well if we make it all the way through i
want to point out a few things here he's
still got the flag up here he's still
got the bong crack pipe glass dildo
whatever the hell that thing is on the
shelf yeah still like still tvd and then
if you look down here you see that down
below a shoulder game there it seems to
be like a bag uh you know i don't take a
blue bag yeah it's like a blue leather
case i don't know if it's a bowling ball
or if he's got jars of johnny depp's
cocaine in there
but it i don't know it just seems like
it seems like cocaine would work in that
bag a lot i'm just saying and after you
see this video you'll know what i'm
talking about he has a problem hiding
his his drug paraphernalia in the videos
but let's let's watch it's the gun it's
not the sociopath wielding it folks
is is he talking about himself i i'm not
a sociopath
but here's the thing even if it was a
sociopath which again all these people
want to say it's no
it's not the goon it's not the goon it's
a sociopath well if it's a sociopath
then what are we doing if it's a
sociopath with mental illness what are
we doing i'm sorry don junior your dad
rolled back an obama era regulation that
made it easier that anyone can have it
especially the mentally ill so when
these people want to go around and say
this guy who had a mental illness he
should have had the gun he passed the
background checks i wonder why he passed
the background checks because you guys
[ __ ] removed the check that said he
shouldn't get the gun in the first place
right
you know i'm really thinking that donald
trump jr is trying to copy me man he
used to be a clean shaven and had that
stupid [ __ ] haircut but now he's got
the beard he's sitting in his chair
and i know i don't have any drug pail
for me but i do have this sign behind me
here that says nugs not drugs yeah i
don't know what he's thinking drugs he's
got the t-shirt on he went from he went
from a fake ass twenty thousand dollar
suit which aren't actually twenty
thousand dollar suits they're fake
and he went to the t-shirts i feel like
he's trying to copy me here i'm just i'm
just saying let's listen
he'd be a wonderful human being
i used to have the dick my king you know
the mic
he needs to he needs to get it we can
add that post yeah well you know maybe
we can add that in post yeah that's a
good idea he wouldn't have done the
exact same thing with a bat
or a bomb
or some some other improvised device or
no no he wouldn't know he wouldn't judge
him
here's the point and he ran right
through it
pretend that even the biggest psychos
are totally great for fear of reprisal
for fear of the lawsuits for fear of
being stigmatized and maligned is she
gonna cry i don't know if she's gonna
sound like this is a convention like
he's saying that people who are
stigmatized
lawsuits and they want to be the person
that's going to get like is he he seems
to be uh discovering himself especially
his father who loves to litigate to
avoid any sort of accusation or or court
uh uh appearance right you know
i think he freebases coke i don't think
he just snorts it i mean this guy
definitely rebases this [ __ ]
i mean it's
it's joe biden
ourselves for stating those things and
calling out the obvious
that's what's going on right now guys
enough is enough we have been coddled
for too long we teach to the lowest
common denominator
failing anyone who had a chance beyond
that
we pretend that everything is
is great and fine because we can't
acknowledge anymore that people are
screwed up
it's just the word salad now like he was
going somewhere with it but now it's
just i don't even know what the [ __ ]
he's talking about i mean we're at a
point now where i feel like he's just
making a connection
like i honestly think this is him
i think i think there are levels of
uh don junior of high right there's like
the
i'm going a mile a minute and i'm just
saying whatever i think you know and it
might be a lot of words down and buzz
words
then there's another level he's like i'm
kind of you know i'm kind of high
whatever i can still maybe the edibles
kicked in at that maybe but i think
there's another level here which is once
he like [ __ ] breaks through these
other two
it becomes a confession because now
because like when you're going up on the
high he's like yeah yeah let's go let's
go like this is great it's great and
then when he comes down on the high
it's more of a it's more of a somber
depressing tone right and he's seen the
reality of the world he lives in like oh
[ __ ] i'm not this world [ __ ] sucks
that i'm in right right whether or not i
played a part in creating that world
that [ __ ] sucks that i'm in i'm this
person now that i'm like oh [ __ ] and he
has this kind of
coming to light moment i think on his
way downward on the high and i think
that's what we're seeing right here oh
okay
we're on the downward slope oh yeah
we're beginning to see more of
confessing happening in anything i see
well you know i don't want to stigmatize
anyone with the drug habit either
because all kinds of people have a drug
habit right i just want this guy to get
the help that he deserves but i
definitely want him to stop shouting
word salad into his [ __ ] phone and
acting like he's the common man which he
is not you're not a common man you piece
of [ __ ] don't even act like
i was on a point or billy even without
the coke or the drugs or whatever he's
on right now
don jr is still a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
well yeah yeah you're not gonna get the
drugs aren't gonna do anything on off
he's still a [ __ ] right yeah he's not
you're never gonna get rid of it i mean
his name last name is trump let's finish
listen to donny's video here because i
want to get to another [ __ ] here uh
with that that about uh our title but
then let's let's finish donny
we can't acknowledge what the actual
causes are it's not you know a drug
addict mother and a missing father and a
lack of religion it seems like he is oh
my god
i have not seen this video i didn't have
seen this i honestly didn't watch it all
the way through i tweeted this with like
the first 15 [ __ ] seconds i watched
15 seconds i'm like well i'm i know that
what this is i'm tweeting it i have not
seen this video
but are we not witnessing a confession
happening here it is a self-realization
of what is happening you have to
download this [ __ ] you may need to get i
know from donny here you may get a phone
call let's let's finish oh my god the
missing mother the missing father
oh jesus christ no real addiction the
drug addiction oh [ __ ]
indoctrination programs in our schools
you crazy teachers
uh you're teaching some of the crap i've
been talking about in this video it's
none of those
that's some of the crap he talks about
in this video
oh [ __ ] this guy things
it never ends man cry
it's obviously not the total lack of any
discipline patience perseverance you
know that that's just gone from society
it has nothing to do with that guys it's
none of those things it's whatever we
can throw a pill at that makes it go
away it's not a real problem
everyone wins it's fine
this is probably yeah i guarantee when
he was growing up he was medicated his
his dad obviously wasn't around he was
going through therapy he was giving a
therapist that was like hey listen you
know what i think that we should do is
maybe want to put don jr on some
medication because he seems kind of like
a little bit separated from reality or
like he's not really having the same
kind of empathetic connections with
other children and his people in the
class we think that maybe the divorce
and the the marriages have kind of taken
a toll on him
um and he can't really like identify who
he is and so
wow
he's obviously mad at his history i mean
experience his experience speaks through
his word sale was it i mean i'm just i
again i have not seen that video but i
was it's a joke it's [ __ ]
are you excited are you i was excited
but also the fact that like
holy [ __ ]
that was almost to the tier what i said
literally right before that right right
okay gabe tweeted this out we truly live
in the dumbest timeline about a patriot
takes video that we're gonna watch here
marger taylor green says the government
is planning to zap people inside their
bodies oh boy if they try to eat a real
cheeseburger this is [ __ ] real this
is not fake this is also so she has her
own little show this is the third
episode in her mtg live series that she
does on on on facebook i have downloaded
this episode because i'm going to go
after it in one of the upcoming segments
maybe after this second episode i'll do
my episode three on her episode oh my
god you're gonna have to do like 12 of
these [ __ ] ideas this thing is 53
minutes long i have not are you serious
i haven't yes she does an hour of this
stuff yeah well congratulations when she
gets to two hours let me know yeah yeah
she'll really be in competition with
this now i want to point out a few
things here
number one
um she's way too close to her background
way too close look marge if you're gonna
do this
don't do this half-ass or three-toed you
need to [ __ ] do this all the way you
need to back up from your [ __ ]
background a bit right you got to have
some space behind you it creates depth
in the picture okay the other thing too
is that [ __ ] microphone is way way
off yeah [ __ ] up number one sounds
very empty
well it is very empty because she
doesn't have any treatment right like
she named treatment well there's all
kinds of treatment that i have in front
of me so i don't make sure that my body
i don't know if she's on the road
because she has another
like let's see is there another studio
yeah there's another studio and i'll try
to i'll try to see if i can get i'll
just i'll just give you a screenshot
well
but here's here's the thing is her mic
technique is horrible because she's got
it facing the wrong goddamn direction
okay that's why i put my microphone you
know everyone makes fun of this big ass
[ __ ] yeti microphone here mic yeah
and my um
but it listen there's there's a certain
technique that you have with the
microphone and when i first started
podcast you can go listen like episode 1
through 30. my mic technique was
horrible but i had to learn how to use
the mic technique but you think that
this woman has been on trader steve
bannon's trader tv numerous times you
think she'd have mic technique down but
she does not so you know that she's a
[ __ ] bonehead right you know that
she's just [ __ ] dumber
than a [ __ ] box of rocks here nuttier
than squirrel turds too because she said
some really weird [ __ ] so beyond the
whole she's way too close to the wall
she doesn't have good mic form
listen to the some of the [ __ ] that she
says
here and
listen to when she talks about bill
gates
it's very important that you listen to
the words she says listen you have to
accept the fact that the government
totally wants to provide surveillance on
every part of your life
uh she wants the government to private
surveillance on
what your kid is learning what math
they're learning what history they learn
she also wants to make sure that you
have no control over your uterus she
probably wants to stop you at state
borders to make sure you're not having
any birth control inside of you or
taking any birth control you know stuff
like that but let's listen to what she
thinks the government's gonna do
[ __ ] wacky
they want to know when you're eating
they want to know if you're eating a
cheeseburger which is very bad because
bill gates wants you to eat his fake
meat that grows in a peachtree dish
what did she say
she said yeah she go ahead and say
she said peach
tree
dish like not a not a petri dish so like
a peach like like a fruit like a peach
and a tree uh-huh and then a dish not a
not a petri dish but a peach tree
dish
because you know and now some people
could get confused but she is from
georgia
i know i know i know it's like yes you
could say georgia peaches all that stuff
but she's also the same one that
believes in gazpacho police she's also
the one that believes in jewish space
lasers right oh my god this [ __ ]
bonehead
oh the pete i gotta back it up we gotta
listen to it again let's let's listen to
the hamburger cheeseburger thing let's
do it if they want to know when you're
eating yeah they want to know if you're
oh it's scary
scary very bad because bill gates wants
you to eat his fake meat that grows in a
peachtree dish
you know there's a theory out there and
it's q a this is queuing on this is
queuing on [ __ ] gabe this isn't [ __ ]
some wacky thing that she just says q
and on type [ __ ]
there are people out there that actually
believe that bill gates is buying up all
the farmland so that you can't farm
cattle now here's the first thing bill
gates is um you know he's a really rich
dude he's a billionaire like elon musk
and he has the right to buy twitter he
could buy
you know he could buy oil you know he
could buy commodities he could buy
anything he wants he can even buy land
that's the thing you can do in this
country
just like all the elon stands love that
elon's not ever gonna own twitter he's
just pretending to buy it um it sounds
like you might be doing a video on that
soon too
but
but they're really against him buying
land which is not a thing that he's
doing but they also think he has peach
tree dishes not
pizza
not petri
peach peach tree tree
dish
okay let's finish the rest of this wacky
ass [ __ ] so you'll probably get a little
zap inside your body and that's saying
no no don't eat a real cheeseburger you
need to eat the fake the fake burger you
thought you thought when she was like oh
growing meat and they're gonna count how
many cheeseburgers you're like oh that
sounds crazy that's as crazy as this
video is gonna get and then the next
thing out of her mouth is like they're
gonna
what the [ __ ] does that even how are
they gonna zap you what does that i
don't even know like you think you you
think you've seen it all you think
you're like hey
this is pretty low in terms of
intelligence
and then you're like oh no
30 just three seconds later and you you
just you just you went lower this is
amazing this is honestly it's impressive
and also sad but it's impressive that
you were able to totally
break my expectation of how shitty and
how dumb you are
whack-a-doo's gonna do what
whack-a-doo's gonna do let's finish it
the fake meat from bill gates um they
probably also want to know when you go
to the bathroom and if your bowel
movements are are on time or consistent
i mean what else do these people want to
know
okay so okay
yeah so i i commented on their post
about this i said i want to find out who
is laughing at these jokes in the
background and i said it's matt gates
probably
it oh matt gates in the background which
i'm also surprising that he would let
this [ __ ] show of a podcast happen when
he's got his own studio set for his fire
brand you know like i it's it is insane
but then again
he did go on uh he did go on tv and do
an interview and when they were doing
their america first tour he said it gets
really stuffy in these hotel rooms
spending a lot of time together him and
marjory taylor green so look i don't
know if something happened i definitely
made a video where marjory taylor green
walks in the background but
i will say this they do spend a lot of
time in these kind of uh stuffy hotel
rooms that kind of look like a hotel
room possibly so i wouldn't be surprised
if matt gates is back there
giggling away yeah well you know i think
this is projection too this is
absolutely projection they definitely
want to track um what birth control you
can have what you can't have they want
to track what you can and can't do with
your body they probably want to put an
implant in anyone who would even
thinking about abortion so they could
zap them if they ever think about it
ever again because these fascists are
it's a hundred percent projection we see
with ted cruz we see with every one of
them every single [ __ ] one of them
it's always projection and this is what
marjory taylor green wants she wants the
space lasers she wants
the gazpacho and she definitely wants to
grow
your baby inside of a
peach hmm
very odd i'm glad you joined us here
today on this holiday
memorial day
as we do every single day monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific
youtube twitter twitch go ahead and
subscribe to the youtube channel you are
not going to want to miss a thing
not going to want to miss thing we also
simulcast
from the facebook page of midas touch
and check out all of our clips over on
the minus touch youtube channel they're
doing really well so go over there
as well and download every single
episode on apple spotify google your
favorite
your favorite directory
we got a lot of new audience listeners
a lot of new listeners out there thank
you for coming and joining us today on
this great memorial day don't forget to
remember all the fallen
that fight
and continue to fight
and continue to fall for our freedom for
our liberty not some fake-ass [ __ ] that
these fish fascists want to sell about
peach tree dishes and hamburgers and
cheeseburgers go eat you some real
[ __ ] hot dogs and hamburgers folks
until tomorrow
surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking